- Thank you for making this
show special and being here.
- Oh man, well, thank you for having me
and allowing me to make it special.
- All right, all right.
- Yes.
- How special can I make it?
I can do like whatever?
- Make it your own.
You're a producer I know,
so what do you, yeah.
- So like pretty much
whatever I wanna do to make it my own
I can?
- Let's do it.
- I'm leaning in.
Watch me lean in.
- [Kevin] Whatever I want?
- Yes.
I mean conditions.
- I mean, no.
Whatever I want that's fine.
- What do you think?
- Just like as a test,
if I wanted to make it like
a different color out here,
can I mess with lights?
- A different vibe?
We can...
Darren, come on,
help him out, lights.
- Can you give me
something red 'cause I feel sexy?
(Kelly laughs)
I feel hot.
- You feeling red?
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, can you
get me something?
- Red light special, TLC.
- Give me something--
Hey, hey, there we go.
All right.
- I like the red light special.
- I like that.
We're going red light special.
- Yes, yes.
- Following K Hart Lite.
I like it.
♪ All of the night ♪
- It was a good song.
- I mean I came out to
like some good music
but I feel like, there's a
there's a little more umph
than I would have had if I
could have asked for something,
a little more drum,
a little more drum.
- You looking for--
(band beats drums)
- Okay, okay, okay.
(upbeat music)
- [Kevin] Yeah!
- [Kelly] Hey! (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, oh!
(Kelly laughs)
Yeah!
- You did it!
- Yeah.
- Oh, my God, I love you.
- Now we're talking.
- You got some moves.
- Go ahead.
- You saw that?
- I did.
The electric slide there
at the end, I liked that.
- Older you get the
less space you take up.
Right here.
It looked like I'm doing
a bunt but I'm in my box.
I'm not going outside my box right here.
Hey, I like it.
I like it.
- All right, I like that too.
- And I can do this pretty
much throughout the show?
- Yeah, this is your show today with me.
- Done.
- Of course, yes.
- Done, say no more.
- What do you think about the title,
"The Kelly Clarkson Show?"
Do you think we should
do something with that?
- Yeah, if it's my show
then, I don't think
it should just be--
- It's your show, yeah.
- I don't think it
should just be your name.
So let's change--
- Okay.
Let's put my name in there too
somehow like--
- What's your graphic?
- "The Kevin," "The Kevin
Hart," "Kevin Hart's,
"Kevin Hart's Kelly Clarkson Show,"
Something like that, yeah.
- Okay, your name first, okay.
- [Kevin] Yeah, put my name first.
- [Kelly] Yeah, your name first.
That sounds good.
Okay, I'm still leaning in.
- [Kevin] Now we're talking about it.
That's what I'm talking about.
- [Kelly All right.
- Change it.
Did they change the graphic?
Change it.
- Yes, they did, look.
- "Kevin Hart's," there
it is right at the top.
- There we go.
- Bam, right at the top!
- Bam!
(audience applauds)
- Top line, I got it, I got it, okay.
- I like it, okay.
- We're also here to
talk about fatherhood.
So like maybe we should
honor that somehow.
- We should.
Hold on.
Can we do like a graphic going to that
'cause I took notes?
- Oh, you took notes.
I got like little notes like--
- Oh, okay on the
Kelly Clarkson (indistinct)
- You could
just do something like
"Kevin Hart's" like,
I don't know,
like fathers and kids
or something like that.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Like something with me
like driving conversation towards that.
So just put something in there too like
"A tribute to Rad Dad," okay.
- "A Tribute to Rad Dads."
- "To Rad Dads," okay.
- All right.
- Who is doing that 'cause I like him?
- We are good.
We're Emmy-winning so
right when you say it,
it just fricking happens.
- It happens.
I like that.
I mean the other thing.
I don't know.
Occasionally, can I get
hit with a spotlight?
You got a spotlight.
- A spotlight, yes.
We have a spotlight.
- If I wanna get hit with a spotlight
every now and then.
- Just to where I'm just not in it at all.
- Just to where we can
kind of a dull you out a little bit.
(Kelly laughs)
Just hit me with a
spotlight every now and then
when I'm talking
and just make sure that
there's a big lighting
difference between me and Kelly.
There you go.
- Let them know who's important.
- Yeah, just sometimes I talk,
I may just want a spotlight.
I know it adds to what I'm saying.
It makes me feel more powerful.
It makes me feel like--
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah, see my stance change?
Having spotlight (indistinct)
Welcome, welcome, hey, hey!
- Welcome to "Kevin Hart's."